hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll you know in some sense as it's
been often pointed out podcasts aren't
that different in spirit from just radio
shows right we've had shows on the radio
for a very long time but of course
there's also a difference and a lot of
the difference between good
old-fashioned radio shows and newfangled
podcasts is the device by which you are
receiving this podcast
it could be a portable device right a
phone or a tablet or it might be your
laptop but this new bit of extra
technology lets you do what makes
podcasts great which is you can listen
whenever you want right it's not like a
radio show you have to wait for that
time you can pause it you can skip
through the parts you find interesting
and so forth it's a tiny change maybe
but it's an important one that has been
made possible by this bit of technology
these devices we carry around with us
and it's just one example about how
these devices have really been
transforming our lives and arguably even
ourselves who we are we identify with
and use our devices in ways that really
hit who we are deep down and maybe the
world's leading expert in this
phenomenon is today's guest sherry
turkle sherry's a professor at mit who
started out studying psychology and has
a degree in psychology that's her phd
but she became interested early on
in the idea of technology and how it
affects our psychology so she got a job
at mit
founding a new way of thinking about the
relationship between human psychology
and machines and technology right at the
beginning of artificial intelligence and
the personal computer revolution and so
forth and even though she was initially
quite optimistic about how we can use
technology to make the human experience
a better one
these days she finds herself i think i
would accurately say more often pointing
out the worries that we should have not
that she's anti-technology in any way
but there are ways in which the
technology sometimes moves ahead of our
ability to understand what is going on
we all know how devices are extremely
seductive we can't put down our phones
the young generation we have right now
is growing up in a very different
environment than older generations did
because of how they relate to technology
and to each other
it's something where in some sense
the art of conversation of spontaneity
of not knowing exactly what you want to
say and therefore spitting something out
and maybe it's not exactly right and you
have to edit that's a kind of art form
or even just sitting in silence that you
don't need to face up to when you have
this technological mediation how does
that change who we are who we want to be
who we present ourselves as to the rest
of the world sherry has a new book out
which is actually a memoir it's called
the empathy diaries
a memoir is the subtitle and the idea of
writing a memoir is because she does
have this interesting intellectual place
where she's sitting and she wanted to
try to explain how she got there through
her personal story and the empathy
diaries is an appropriate title because
she wants to emphasize the importance of
empathy and personal connection in an
age where machines dominate our
communication so strongly i say all this
of course knowing perfectly well that i
am recording this podcast on just such a
bit of technology and you are listening
to it on just such a bit of technology
so again not anti-technology here but
this is exactly the kind of situation
where we shouldn't let our enthusiasms
run away without thinking about it being
cognitive really trying to understand
where we're going rather than just
racing willy-nilly from one shiny object
to another that's what this podcast is
trying to get us in the mood to do so
let's go
[Music]
sherry turkle welcome to the mindscape
podcast
my pleasure so this is an unusual um
interview i've interviewed plenty of
people who have books out but you have a
memoir out which is a little bit of a
departure but i think it works well
because
we can use some of your biography to get
into some of the substantive thing that
you've done over the years in technology
and communication and so forth so
explain to the audience how you had a
career path of becoming a psychologist
and a clinical psychiatrist i guess and
ended up at mit thinking about
technology
well um
you sort of had to be there at the time
but really that's why i wrote the memoir
the memoir is not a personal um
memoir the memoir is a memoir of a very
particular kind
it's a it's a memoir that
tries to integrate
it's in the spirit of the question you
just asked because it tries to integrate
my personal story
and how i ended up doing the work
uh
that i do
so it answers that very question i went
to mit
because i
um
wanted to
uh
have a place to finish a book i was
writing
about
how
intellectual ideas get into the public
space
um
uh and sort of hit the street
after they've been in the seminar room
so my case study
was actually the popularization
of
french psychoanalysis
in the years after 1968.
there was this very esoteric
guy named jacques blackkaw hardly
anybody read him very hard to read very
opaque and then there were these may
events kind of parallel to the french
student movement we had here
and all of a sudden jacques lacall was
like a movie star
everybody was in psychoanalysis
everybody was quoting this very you know
hardly understanding him i guess
but psychoanalytic ideas were really in
the popular culture in a very big way
and i was fascinated by this question of
how ideas that are
in academia
really become part of public discourse
in particular ideas about thinking about
the self
because that really influences
therapeutic practice that's what my
thesis was that's what all my study
had been about
was about how really in a culture
you can only help people to get better
um
from what's troubling them
if you use
the ideas that are in the culture
you know you need to use the ideas
uh that are popular in the culture to
get through to people and explain their
troubles to them
in the metaphors that they can
understand
so in american society freudian ideas
talking to people about their repression
or their oedipus complex or their
you know
their their childhood
that had been kind of in the public
imagination for 30 40 50 years
and not at all in france those ideas had
been shunned
and then all of a sudden in the 60s they
were very much of the popular culture
and i studied that process and i went to
mit
uh because there was a dean there who
thought this work
was very very relevant
to thinking about how artificial
intelligence
and was going to get out and ideas about
thinking about the computer
were going to get out into the popular
culture
ideas like
don't interrupt me i need to clear my
buffer
having enough bandwidth yes
no
i don't want you to reprogram me
you know um
you know ideas that represented the mind
as a machine
how were those ideas going to
get out
and they felt they sort of needed
someone like me
someone who was not a computer expert
but a sort of expert on
how ideas hit the street yeah
um move from the classroom and the
laboratory into the culture
to think about the new ideas of
computers and artificial intelligence
and i was writing up my dissertation as
a book and i said that sounds
interesting
and i sort of went
to see
and i absolutely fell in love with the
question right i absolutely fell in love
with the question and you know 40 more
years later
i'm just as much in love with this
question
of
how for example
these ideas about the metaverse now
are going to change our ideas about
thinking about is reality important yeah
or are we okay
that we're going to leave reality and go
to the metaverse
all of a sudden you have all these
very influential people then i want to
live in the metaverse let's all make
avatars in the metaverse let's spend a
lot of money in the metaverse we're
going to have commerce and meetings and
lovers in the metaverse
well what about reality
you know
who's going to take care of
business i mean does that mean that
we're going to be sold on the idea that
not only isn't face-to-face reality
important but
reality reality isn't important either
you know can we can we not take care of
our streets and our homes and our
our public parks and our
our our offices and our you know train
stations because we're just going to go
to the metaverse instead of
you know being in the physical in
physical space well we don't need to go
to i mean i i don't want to go on and on
but it's the same sort of question
which is just as
you know just as compelling now as then
so that's how i made the transition yeah
from studying you know ideas from freud
and how they changed people's lives to
studying ideas from technology and how
they change really how we think about
living you know we did not
that was the transition not too long ago
we had a lacanian uh psychoanalyst uh or
psychoanalytical theorist on the
mindscape podcast mari rudy and i just
want to let anyone know who enjoyed that
one that there are some very good lacan
stories in uh your memoir sherry yes he
was a character
paris i went to paris and i um
i basically said to him listen um
i'm writing a book about the impact of
your ideas on
popular culture where everybody was
making something of this this man's
ideas different things
and usually opposite things
and i said but you've gotta you know
explain to me here's some of your ideas
because i'm really having some
trouble here
and he uh you know i think he saw me in
french there's an expression you know
lydia duvillage i mean sort of like not
a village idiot exactly but some sort of
naive you know like
and he
he who has a reputation for great
opacity
said yeah i'll explain i'll explain this
to you
and he was actually a very sensitive and
very kind uh teacher to me
um and i tried to in in this book and in
everything i've written about him tried
to communicate
you know how he explained his ideas to
me in a way that
you know i could understand and you had
the hot spot to invite him to give a
seminar at mit which did not go exactly
well as i recall
but let's get into this mindset because
it is a great you know sort of right
place right time story where someone
like you
at mit
in the 70s when it was sort of the the
first heyday of artificial intelligence
and people were
like you said
you know part of that is building
artificial intelligence algorithms but a
flip side of that is thinking of human
beings as machines right we human beings
always do that the latest technology is
the metaphor we use to start thinking
about ourselves so you know how did that
feel back then in in the 70s were you
optimistic were you like oh yeah human
beings are going to be machines or were
you already a little bit
worried that people were taking this too
straightforwardly too far well i was i
was very worried because my background
was to see
um
to me it was a i called it a move from
meaning to mechanism
from looking the first the first thing
that had hit me and the thing that had
compelled me to to do this
i was teaching a course
uh that had a unit uh on an introduction
to freud
and i was trying to explain what called
what we call freudian slips
and freud in his in his book on slips
and his uh notes on slips
explains freudian slips uh he calls them
parapraxis by
by saying by giving an example
of a chairman
who calls a meeting to order
but instead of calling the meeting to
order he says it's i call the meeting
closed
in other words the substitutes closed
for open in the meeting
and um then he goes with a whole long
rigorous mole about how he might have
done that why he did that his wife is
sick so he wants to get home
his and he's ambivalent about what's
going to happen in the meeting i mean
all the meaning
reasons that a freudian would give to
unpack
that slip
and a a hand is raised in the back of
the room
of a computer scientist
who says i
think that you're looking at this in the
wrong way
in a webster's dictionary closed and
open or as far away as cno
in a freudian dictionary they're
opposites
closed and open or as far away as you
can get you have to go into all these
meanings and ambivalence and
his wife is sick and
but in a computational dictionary closed
equals minus open
a symbol has been dropped right when you
make that mistake there's been a power
surge one bit
one bit there's been no it's no problem
i mean it's like you know nothing
happened you had a
power surge on the line so there's no
you don't need this whole big production
just your there's been a little glitch
in the electricity your brain your mind
your mind is a series of electrical
circuits i mean get a
talk about something interesting i mean
you have a mechanism here there where
nothing very interesting has happened
yeah
and i was so taken aback
because i realized that if you do see
the mind as a machine
she was absolutely right
this whole infrastructure of meaning
depended
on a model
that she didn't believe in
from her point of view there was no
there was no there there
in this story
and i saw that a
a structure in which you looked for
meaning was shifting to a structure of
mechanism
that was going to have all different
kinds of assumptions
i guess and um
and i tell a story in the empathy
diaries to illustrate
this uh
you know this is what kept me at mit i
mean i was then i was hooked you know i
was about to leave for some liberal
artsy place you know but then i was just
hooked
and i went to the um
uh debut of the movie tron oh yeah
original with marvin minsky who thought
the mind was a meat machine that's how
he said the mind doesn't mean he uh
loved tron because it showed the mind as
a meat machine it showed all the little
programs you know interacting and this
my in the mind
as
little
you know anthropomorphic programs he
loved that
and then he said you know and and
children will go see movies like this
and they'll never see movies like bambi
and i and i and i bit i bit you know he
had me i shouldn't have risen to the
bait but i did i said why not bambi
every kid sees bambi
and he says because in bambi
the children get attached to their
mothers
and the mother dies
and in the world we're going towards
the robots will be immortal
will be taken care of not by the mothers
but by the immortal robots
there'll be no death
will be uploaded onto the compute in
other words he gives me this whole
ai version of how we're on the way to
this
radical self-improvement in ai
and i
realized whoa
you know this just isn't a
a theory this is a whole way of of a
philosophy of being in the world
and i think that that really is what
we're struggling with now even as we
talk about the metaverse
uh
it you know it's not
it or or talk about
robot caretakers for our children or
robot psychotherapists
which is being pushed so much or robot
companions or robots who will love us or
you know all of the
all of the things that are so current
now in our discourse
um
is how much do we care about our bodies
about having human companions about the
specificity of being human all of these
were questions that were posed
for the first time
when i first got to mit now we're living
them out
in real technology
that is being proposed to us
but they were proposed in theory when i
first
got there
i'm interested in that story about the
bit flipping uh in the in the freudian
slip context because i i can kind of see
both sides here i mean uh at a deep
intellectual level i'm sympathetic to
the idea that the mind is a machine that
you know ultimately there's neurons and
the remaining laws of physics etc but of
course it's the kind of machine that is
so enormously more complicated than what
we build on our computers right now that
to think of a human being making that
wrong word choice as just a bit flip is
probably hopelessly naive i would think
well also where where we i think i do
believe along with the
uh
with the tradition and represented by
you know phenomenologists and merlot
ponte and in the computer world by huber
dreyfus
by antonio dimazio that we're a
particular kind of machine that's
attached to our bodies right and
very specific bodies and bodies that
have a life cycle and bodies that feel
pain and bodies that know they're going
to die and bodies that were born
and bodies that
grew up being attached to parents on
whom they were dependent and you know
that that i think that those experience
those embodied experiences
and those experience of dependency and
attachment
really create a specificity of the human
that
even if you have a neuronal accident and
you drop a bit because
you know sometimes a cigar is just a
cigar and you say open when is you mean
closed because let's say you have a
bit drop
you know still
when you do that
it triggers associations
from all of those other systems and with
all of those other consequences
um
so i think that we are more complex
and
i always like to quote you know some
it's so funny that when you write
several books
because
people sometimes say well do you repeat
yourself and i say i intentionally
repeat a couple of times i've
intentionally repeated a story
because i loved it so much
and i i wanted to give the author credit
i don't repeat stories of mine but i
repeat other people's work and peter
cramer wrote a book listening to prozac
quite a few years ago
but he tells a story at the beginning of
listening to prozac i mean it was a very
big book when he wrote it i mean he so
he you know got a lot of credit for how
brilliantly it was written
but i but i give him extra extra credit
because he began it with the following
story that i think sums up the human
condition and the question you've just
asked me so perfectly and the story is
this
that he was a psychiatrist working at
brown university in the counseling
department
and a student comes in he says he's
depressed
and prozac was just coming out and
kramer
gives you know gives the student prozac
for the depression
three weeks later the student comes in
and the student says
i'm not sleeping
and cramer
the last notes he has on his in his
student chart for the chart
says that he gave prozac and he knows
that prozac sometimes leads to sleep
disorders he says not to worry i'll give
you something for the sleeping this
often happens when people take prozac
and the student says to him
no
i didn't take the prozac
i'm
not sleeping because i feel guilty
towards you
about not having followed your
advice right
and cramer says that in the
in less than a heartbeat
in less than a second
i mean it didn't take a second
he went from seeing that student
as a bundle of synapses
that he was going to treat with prozac
and
serotonin at the synapse
to seeing that student
as
an inedible
context and he and the transference and
and
what had happened in the transference to
him and what about his relationship with
his father and as part of a family
system and how was he going to deal with
his family system and his
and his whole relationship to this
completely divorced
from this whole
thing about
the mind is the machine and what the
prozac could do with the synapse et
cetera et cetera et cetera
and and i and he said
that is what is extraordinary about the
human condition
that we
relate we can relate to each other and
at the same time
machine to machine
prozac giver to prosec receiver
and as edible transference figure to sun
and that the way he describes that flip
and then of course he had to slip back
because then he's the question is well
what can prozac you know he still maybe
wants to try prozac you know
but then that way it's that way that we
all live
that really is the human condition that
we are both
and that one doesn't exclude the other
and it's time that we stop
behaving
as though
well we'll just go into the metaverse so
we don't need to be in our bodies
anymore
you know you know
i mean we have to start
stop behaving as though we're on the red
team so we're behaving like we all saw
the matrix and we have to choose between
the red pill and the blue pill
we we have to
actually
our situation is that we don't get to do
one pill or the other pill
we live in the fully hybrid world our
minds now are in a fully hybridized
situation
so we're talking now on i mean i'm you
know you see where i'm going so i'll
start my lecture but but we
but the human condition is that we are
both you know i wish i had known that
story because when i wrote my book the
big picture i talked a lot about how you
can describe the same situation using
different vocabularies that are uh very
different in content but are both right
as long as they're compatible with each
other this is a great example of exactly
it's the same thing except what i think
that happens to clinicians
what happens to people you know what
happens to and this gets back to your
first question about being a clinician
is that if you're a clinician you
operate
you
you have to operate
on both levels
because we do have drugs we do have
medications
that can
we're not to use the medications would
be malpra would be wrong to say no i'm
just talking to
i'm just talking to everybody you know
freddie and mine befriending mind that
would be wrong because these medications
do
calm people down to the point where
they're more accessible for conversation
so
you know
certainly someone like kramer is not a
completely anti-medication person
but
the point then is to have a conversation
with with the more complex
person who did have a relationship with
his father and so when some fancy
psychiatrist said do this
he said hell with that i don't want to
do anyone do anything that an older man
tells me to do uh
no
but then later he came back realizing he
was
yep
you know there was something maybe to
learn here
well now he was depressed and angry at
peter kramer and angry at his father and
still depressed and maybe there was
something to get out of this experience
and speaking of conversations this this
provides a wonderful segue because um
it is a different world that we're now
that we were in the 70s in terms of how
this technological revolution is going
to affect us and i think that the idea
of
people carrying around small mobile
devices that are conduit to interacting
with the whole world was probably not
nearly
as appreciated in the 70s as it is uh
manifest to us right now so you've done
a lot of work and thought a lot about
how
having these devices changes how we
behave but also who we are in fact you
already mentioned the fact as antonio
demacio was another former podcast guest
and he and others have really emphasized
the existence of the body as an
important part of who we are and now in
some sense these little phones and ipads
and laptops that we carry around are
becoming extensions of our body and
changing who we are
yes i mean i actually in the empathy
diaries i talk about
the uh the change in my work because in
the beginning that my first book when i
got to mit and i saw
this new world of
devices and and and ai and thinking of
the mind as a machine and the way people
i called my first book the second self
because i saw the way people were
projecting themselves onto the computer
i called it an evocative object i
because it was sort of on the border
between mind and not mind i thought it
was a
place where people were exploring their
sense of self and their question of
free will and i i even said what sex was
the victorians
the question of free will is to our
generation
that the the programming brings up that
question of free will that i mean i i i
wasn't positive i was talking about all
of these
very you know these these big questions
that ai raised but it was a it was a
book of discovery and exploration
then
when the
mobile phone
and i wrote another book that was very
positive which is a book called life on
the screen
where i talk about people going into
muds and things like the metaverse and
playing sims and second life and you
know again exploring through avatars
gender and their personality and taking
on different roles and doing
role-playing and i saw the dangers but i
also talked about them as identity
workshops and placed you know how uh
cyberspace was a place to play with
identity again i talked about the
problems i talked about addiction i
talked about i mean i talked about a lot
of things but my
attitude was these are places of
psychological possibility let's study
them i'm basically an empiricist i'm not
a moral philosopher but
when i saw that people were walking
around
[Laughter]
with the world of computation
to enter
you know
you know just
like that sherry is holding up her phone
uh to her
i'm applying it directly to my head
i
my attitude shifted
because my model
of how people had been using the phone
as an identity device
involved
sitting on your couch with your friends
and your family and your baby and your
lover your mother your brother
and your
and
then walking away
going to your office sitting at your
computer and have doing some identity
exploration yeah and then getting up
from your chair
and walking back to your living room and
being with your family again in other
words it was a
it was a going to the place
of
therapy or experimentation
or or you know
you know being in a parallel universe
and then coming back to the real
right and
what the phone did is it broke that
barrier so the people were cycling
through
people were cycling i called it cycling
through that when in the in the original
model people kind of cycled through the
reel and this metaverse
and then the cycling through became the
rapid cycling
became so rapid that the boundaries
broke down yeah and people were going
back and forth and back and forth and
back i mean the people said i i i real
that the that the world really that they
were accessing from their phone was more
real
than their real life was often more
compelling than their real life and what
distresses me now
is that people are saying
let me just not say people like mark
zuckerberg or anybody who's pushing the
metaverse which is increasingly like a
lot of companies because they're going
to make a lot of money on it they're
saying that's right we are going to make
the metaverse
more compelling than the real you're
going to want to work in the metaverse
you're going to want to play in the
metaverse you're going to want to and i
i saw a new yorker cartoon that was i've
i was trying to
explain it to some friends and i think
i'm going to make it like my holiday
card
it was it was like a cartoon about
things that we're going to have a hard
time explaining to the next generation
you know like things that will be
difficult for
my grandchildren to like understand how
it used to be
where
a grandmother is with her grandchild
and
the grandmothers has oculus glasses on
and she's saying to the grandchild okay
now when we're together now in the
metaverse do you see me with these
goggles or do you just see me
or
do you see me without the goggles and
the little grandchild says to the
grandmother oh no grandma i see you as a
unicorn because that's the avatar i've
made for you
so the grandmother says you mean you
don't see me your grandma when i visit
you
and the grandchild says no no i it's
just you you're you're a unicorn and
grandmother says what's the point
[Laughter]
why do you need me
so if you don't see me what's
what's the point of this visit um
deep question there
and i mean
now we're pushing that the you know the
the
it was it was so touching to me because
because you know i like it so much that
i can see you i mean your listeners
don't know but i can actually see you it
helps the conversation it means
everything to me that i can see you yeah
i mean
if you were just there as a little
avatar a little unicorn i mean
what's the
how's that going to help me i mean i see
you i see your books i see
your guy who has posters i mean
i don't know it's just nice
well i guess i mean yeah the metaverse i
wasn't planning to go there but it's a
it is a compelling
thing um i mean let's let's let let me
pretend to push back because i think i
get your first back yeah i think i get
your point but um
in the metaverse you know we call it the
metaverse i guess because facebook
decided that's what they wanted to be
virtual reality yeah virtual reality i i
had a little house in second life i've
given talks in second life etc you know
they're not very advanced
technologically um but you know you can
look however you want you can live
however you want uh you can travel by
teleporting or flying i see the
attraction there um how how should we
think about
using that in the original optimistic
sense of identity workshops
yeah i mean i've studied that for years
and years and and i'm
completely um
i mean i was a great fan of that because
it has very powerful very positive
things to it you you get to play with
identity you get to play people can play
with gender
young people can be old you get to play
with what it's like to be an old person
if you're young and how you're treated
if you're a woman you get to see the
kind of authority you have as a man if
you if you're short you get to be tall i
mean i remember being i mean i'm five
i say i'm five four but i'm lying i'm
really five three and a half and i get
to see what would be like to be five
eight yeah five nine even it's different
experience i mean you you know you just
it is a very powerful thing to
to play with elements of identity and to
present yourself in different ways and
and i 100 and these are very that whole
notion of
um i talk in my in my work on this about
eric erickson's idea of the moratorium
about how um about how he wrote about
how in adolescence traditionally people
were allowed to kind of
time out
to try different things to experiment
with different things and there's no
moratorium in american society now i
mean you're you know i mean my god
you know i mean now on facebook i mean
from from from eight you're you're
you're tracked you have a you have a
trail of
but it's not even that you're trapped
there's no
there's no sort of time out you know
there's no idea of there's no notion of
adolescence as a time of no consequence
there's no huckleberry finn tom sawyer
time there's no life on the mississippi
there's no sense of 13 year olds or 13
year olds but that's because 13 year
olds didn't used to carry guns and
you know shoot people i mean you know
there was a sense of
childhood boys will be boys you know
but when people you know when they when
the level of uh
well you know what i mean when the level
of violence and aggression reaches a
certain point you know swiping some uh
you're not you know it it becomes too
much in in any case
that that's out of american life doesn't
have that anymore but it was nice to
have those
that sense of adolescence is a time when
people tried on identities like for
example you know people tried on i'm
gonna i'm gonna try on catholicism there
used to be a lot of
in my circle you know people would try
out being catholic or try out being
muslim or trump people are not
trying out so much religion because it
goes with such a heavy
now that goes with such a heavy overlay
of um
of other meanings
um
so that's what it's good for it's good
for all this trying out
now
um
when the metaverse becomes
or when
augmented reality or virtual reality
really becomes the place where we
live
where consequential decisions are made
where it's where we have our
relationships with where we go to work
where it's where we
you know
where we sculpt a primary sense of
identity where i wake up i put on my
glasses or my contacts or my goggles and
you know that really becomes me
um
our our ways of having conversations
uh
are going to
change our ways of being spontaneous are
going to change our ways of
experiencing our physicality are our our
commitment to um
the environment our commitment to the
city our commitment to what our streets
look like
are going to change our commitment to
what our offices look like
um
if if you if you anticipate that that
four days a week people are going to be
working virtually or even three
uh
you're more likely to say well on the
two days or they come to work well it
doesn't matter so much they're at a
beautiful office or
you know or what their office is like
i mean i think this is really
so much to each other when we're with
each other face to face
there's something very interesting here
and just just
in many ways but with the question of
identity in particular as just one
example i think you you've brought up
sort of
two flip sides one is that
in
virtual spaces we can try on different
identities right on the internet no one
knows you're a dog you know you can you
can play act
but at the same time in our
if you want to call it the real world
our tangible physical uh reality it's
had the opposite effect you can't
reinvent yourself as easily because you
have this
record out there on twitter or facebook
or whatever and i remember there was a
poignant moment in in one of your books
where you mentioned
students in college you know wistfully
saying i guess it used to be possible to
go to college and be a different person
but you can't now because everyone can
look you up on facebook and they know
who you are
yes
yes and the idea that virtual reality
becomes a place for experimentation
because you can somehow try to erase an
avatar
and what about when you can't erase an
avatar anymore
i mean
what makes us think that you know i
think that virtual reality is as as as
as the
as as the metaverse becomes more
corporate
this whole notion of you know its
playfulness is going to go away too
because you're going to be dealing with
real money and selling real things and
you're going to need to have a real
reputation it's not just going to be oh
that was my avatar because i wanted to
work out something
so i mean i you know i think that a lot
of the things that i saw is so positive
about you know uh
this identity space are going to
fade fall off
as it becomes more like it was as it
becomes our real life yeah so basically
we're very concerned about the kinds of
relationships and attachments and
empathy
that people that you that you get avatar
to avatar
um
you know um
because i think that what defines us is
human ultimately
you know this is play time it's great to
have all these technologies and to play
with them and to see their affordances
and to see what they're good for and to
you know i'm i'm not a luddite i think
we should all
try everything and
i don't believe in closing down work on
anything and
nothing like that
but i think we've had a little
experience now and um
i don't think that um
i think we've learned that
too much time online too much time on
screens we don't form the same sorts of
attachments we don't form the same sorts
of
sense of you know responsibility and
connection it's just easy to ghost
somebody
you know the amount of people who end
relationships both
both romantic but also
work relationships
of all sorts relationships of all sorts
you know not just oh my
you know my boyfriend ghosted me but my
colleague ghosted me my friend ghosted
me my by just the sort of vague
talk to you soon
chow chow you know and then somehow
they're you know
they're gone you know they're you know
colleagues and you know
kind of because they can just
not because they they're being mean or
uh
even feel they're being unprofessional
but because they can really
yeah you know i i had a very significant
relationship with with an edit
with an editorial colleague and uh
uh
who
i meant very well and he meant me very
well and then i think it had if all of
our meetings had been
if if our relationships had not been so
internet mediated yeah
things would have ended differently
because this way was just like oh you
know clive chow see you online
and then
emails don't get answered and it just is
very vague or they get answered with a
very cursorily and
just because you can not because people
are trying to be
people can end things and defer things
and not get back to you
and
in business
practice just because they can
and people don't want to be vulnerable
people don't like for example
firing people or rejecting people
professionally i'm not just talking
about in personal life or love but
nobody wants to send a rejection letter
much easier to just not answer
and so not answering becomes like a
a thing
because you can
it's a ghost thing isn't just for
lovers
ghosting is for every level of
professional life you know
i should write a book called ghosting is
not just for lovers there you go i like
that all right i know that ghosting is
not it's a great ghost thing is for
every level of professional uh life well
it speaks to something you know tangible
about this difference because on the one
hand it's easy to say
that
higher levels of connectivity help us
meet and interact with a wider variety
of people and that's good but what
you're pointing out is that
those connections that we make
seem to us much more disposable and
temporary and ephemeral than the ones we
make in
them
to be i mean i had a wonderful you know
and stephen colbert had his um
you know his original show i was on it
was called the colbert reporter one i
was on that program he's such a
brilliant man and he
he asked and and i guess alone together
had just come out and he interviewed me
for that book and
it was such a privilege because he's so
brilliant and he asked me the following
question he said
in character as you know
whoever he was the character he was
playing the stephen colbert character
and the question was
don't all those little sips of
connection
add up to one big gulp
of conversation yeah
and i said no no
they don't
but it was it was the greatest question
it was exactly the question
because a thousand sips of connection
during the day
are not the same as sitting down with
somebody and saying look i've sent you
i've sent you a p i've sent you my
artwork
for critique i want to know if your
gallery is interested in me
you've had it for a year i've gotten
nothing
could
you know i i i'd like
you've had my slides could we have a
five minute conversation
that
about
about them
and whether
you i should be considering you as a
gallery from my future if i should move
on
and that conversation
you know doesn't happen right
you can't
i mean i'm not an artist but i've
interviewed enough artists to know that
that
doesn't happen well and what i like
about the the analysis you give of this
is that
you make the point that a lot of things
we would think of as
um
bugs or uh disadvantages of
person-to-person conversation are
actually features right are actually
things that are really necessary the
awkwardness the silence
the
getting it not quite right the first
time you say it right i mean
you try to make the point that these are
actually useful and helpful parts of the
process not things we should polish away
yes one of my favorite interviews um
on this point
was um
a young woman who was interviewing about
conversation and she says
you know there's a there's an
eight-minute rule
that you have to really listen to
somebody for eight minutes
in order to understand what they're
saying that's a long time they stop they
start i mean if you really want to
understand like if even if you like
somebody
you know we're really like you know not
even romantically but she was talking
like just like who is this person
in her experience it takes eight minutes
you know it says people say it takes
less than a nanosecond for for people to
know if they want to be intimate with
each other but it takes eight minutes
and i'm willing to believe that but it
takes eight minutes
to like figure out
who is this i mean
who is this what what is their
experience where i mean are they like a
child of a holocaust survivor have they
been abused
who am i talking to who am i talking to
is this somebody who's been abandoned is
this somebody who's
you know
spent their life uh trying to carve out
a individual identity i mean who am i
talking to and um
after saying that i'm thinking i found
my goddess and this is my
this is my woman and then she says but i
don't have the patience to do that
i just i i i can't stay away from my
phone that long i've lost my ability
i've lost my ability wow to hang in
there
wow and and um
and i feel that there's a kind of
vicious circle
of
our incapacity for solitude
our incapacity for boredom
our incapacity to stay with people for
eight minutes you know our income
our uh our our incapacity to
just
be
with
you know to just be
with
with people and just kind of take them
in to give them that kind of patience
because in in in the metaverse
something's always happening you're
making
the avatars just don't sit around
uh
kind of you know like a lump you know
it's like a
it's an active environment and we get
used to
uh constant activity
and you know boredom is your imagination
calling to you
and uh so in in
in the empathy diaries what i try to do
is i try to link
you know my personal story and growing
up
uh in a particular kind of household
with with empathy denied me
to my
interest in how important empathy is and
how
you know when you create a technological
environment in which empathy
is going to be denied to a lot of people
um
you know you
and you're going to have robots and chat
bots
not you know who can't show empathy at
all
um how you're playing with fire
and that's really more the uh you know
that's more the messaging i think that i
that that my work now has is that we're
at a point where we
given who we are psychologically
we're playing with fire
with who we are psychologically as
humans
how well
how old do we understand psychologically
speaking why the devices have this pull
on us why it is so hard even though you
know
because we know a lot about human
psychology
we know for example
what makes us compelled
to
stay at something
you know we're compelled by
devices that
engage us with rage for example we know
that we're engaged by being angry we
know that we're engaged by anxiety we
know that we're engaged by
uh not having stable feedback but by
having intermittent positive feedback or
you know so all of the
so fade facebook's algorithms engage us
by keeping us angry by keeping us on the
edge of our seat by giving us
intermittent feedback and by keeping us
in a silo with other people who agree
with us and who would make and make us
angry and angrier and you know
so the more we so
where it's like we're a slot machine
that's been designed specifically for us
when we sit down to play a video game or
when we sit down to do a little facebook
we think we're just doing a little
talking to our friends but everything is
designed to keep us in a
to get mad
to stay with people who are going to
keep us mad that's a that's a way and to
be shown ads for things that we really
are pre-tested to know that
we want
so
we're we're sort of like a trembling
string of purchase
purchase
being made angry being shown more
pictures of things are going to make me
angry i mean you know it's not just
people who are being made angry by being
told that there's you know you know it's
not just people on the right who are
being made angry yeah
i'm on the line i'm on the left and i'm
being i'm being constantly revved up by
being shown things that are going to
make me angry and angrier on the left in
other words sometimes people get this
wrong impression that oh it's only
people on the right who are being showed
pizzagate and you know thing crazy
things crazy
you know um
you know uh
stories of things that couldn't possibly
be true about vaccines or stuff no is
everybody being shown things that are to
make me crazy about canadian truckers
and you know and nazi flags being
you know desecrating things that i think
are important so i mean i'm i'm being
whipped up into a into a
into a into a crazed state and then i'm
being thrown in with people who are
gonna who are also
furious and make me feel as though i'm
in a community of
other angry
crazed people and so it's siloing us
into more and more tribal well this
isn't good
i mean obviously this is
yeah so
so your if your question was um
well how does
how does it keep you know
why are we being so compelled is that we
know so much about human psychology and
this all this all this
smart
knowledge is being turned towards making
our devices compelling to us
is it a good analogy to think of it like
almost as empty calories you know uh we
seek out sugary sweet things because 10
000 years ago it was hard to get
calories and you know we were trained to
look for those and now that's not really
the best thing we can we can have for
our health and likewise you know these
psychological techniques
that our devices or our social media use
to hook us
you know are are giving us something we
do want but it's sacrificing something
harder and and more important is that a
good way of thinking of it
well you know it that's such a good
question i'm not sure that we would be
so um
tempted
if our society wasn't in a period of
such
social fragmentation okay in other words
you know
everything is working in sort of
very
a very
vicious circle of unhappy lockstep
to get us to a point where sitting alone
in our room
uh
getting angry
buying stuff and hanging out with other
angry people
seems like a good idea yeah um
so
you know there are these wonderful
studies about
the
precipitation this is even before covet
but the precipitous decline
in civic organizations
i mean america for all of its um
[Music]
you know terrible problems and systemic
racism it's you know all the things that
you know have
have gotten us into so much trouble
uh inequality and so forth um
it it one of the miracles of the country
no you know de tocqueville noticed it in
1830
was
our
our amazing um
the amazing organization of our uh
civic organizations
our
floor floral
you know
garden clubs
the women's clubs you know the church
organizations the
the choral societies that every
group every county had
the bands that every city had the
the high school marching bands the
organization the parents teachers
associations i mean that if you
moved into a community and you wanted to
make friends
there were there were 15 things in your
community
that were waiting for you yeah
and that those have just been closing at
a clip
and
that
there seems to be very
little pushback
uh
as those close
people are just not feeling that
connection to their communities anymore
as these close
so you know yes you still have religious
organizations you still you know you
know the fact that the catholic church
has had such a terrible
um
you know crisis and such a terrible
encounter with its you know historical
uh
uh its historical uh tragedies
uh
you know was certainly something that
you know had to happen
but you know there go
all of those
um
[Music]
organizations and this is in in this in
the in the parish
that kept people
at
making lunches for each other and
elderly people and kids and you know i
mean
so there's some you know there's a
there's a lot you know it's it's
that's a big loss to a community
and that's true of of religious
organizations across the board
and other kinds of civic organizations
as well
similarly when i was a kid growing up i
lived on a block
where we had a democratic club
and uh i mean god knows what kind of
graft and corruption
[Laughter]
i don't even know you know i have no
comment i haven't studied it
but
uh you know this was just happened to be
a block in brooklyn where i'm sure there
was not a republican you know i mean
this democratic club didn't have to do a
lot of politicking to get vote so and
state they had like um
you know they had speeches and they had
you know
children's fairs and they had
civics lessons and they had i mean
you know they had it was a community and
they had potluck dinners and they had an
elderly program and they had
um
that's not happening anymore
so that's not what the local democratic
club is doing you know it's professional
organizers coming in and
i think potluck dinners and
giving seniors meals
door-to-door giving out food is gone i
guess i'm saying that that we are this
the the society is quite atomized
and
the
the idea of digital friends for example
it's a crazy idea because there's no
friend there
there's no person there to be a friend
and yet i've i've interviewed so many
people who say that seems like such a
good idea to have a digital friend a
friend who can never disappoint you well
i i do think that um again the flip side
of this would be that
there are people who don't fit in to
their local communities and can find
like-minded individuals uh much more
easily over the internet than they can
in physical space and i'm 100
right i'm for it i'm for i mean but
there are two different things
there's using the internet to find other
people
and there's using a program to be a
friend good yeah and i think it's very
important to make this distinction i
love using the internet to find other
people
and then potentially
you convert that relate you know at a
certain point you say hey right
let's
let's have a coffee
you know or uh you know next time you're
you know urine you know urine
if you're far away you know you meet
halfway or you try to find a person
who is not necessarily 3 000 miles away
but you try to find uh
you know people join chess clubs or
playing word games or whatever and they
you know they meet or they
get on zoom or they you know they they
become closer and closer to the reality
of another person there i'm really
you know i
using the internet to to to join with
other humans and to
ultimately get to a meet up with humans
where you can build on that i could not
be more
pro
now i actually see more and more people
wanting to make friends with chatbots
as an alternative
to the vulnerability
of dealing with another person
well this is another if i wasn't making
myself clear is that i actually see a
a slippage
right past
using the internet to talk with other
people
where you're less vulnerable because you
can ghost them or you know kind of just
keep the conversation simple moving
right past that to
you know
to having psychotherapy with a chatbot
and then having a best friend chatbot a
companion chatbot
and you already did mention the idea
that we're building you know robot
therapists or companions for elderly or
kids or or whatever and so are you i
mean what what is your take on that is
it
uh a good stop gap all bad okay all bad
no because it gives have nothing i
really have nothing good to say
because even if the whole point is that
the people who are for it
say the people you can't tell you're
talking to a
if you can't tell you're not talking to
a person
what's the harm
and to me that's the profoundly
yeah dangerous
a profoundly dangerous position i mean
that's a um
that gives up
on the essential of
the human
uh endeavor
it's the it's the turing position you
know if you're talking to a machine and
you can't tell it's a machine the
machine is intelligent
well no
not necessarily it just means the
machine has fooled you into thinking
you're not being able to tell it doesn't
mean that it's intelligent at all
so
would you wanted to make a decision
about war and peace would you wanted to
make a decision about your child would
you wanted to make a decision about
would you want to discuss a relationship
with it would you want to discuss
questions of equity or social justice
with it it has no skin in the game
it doesn't care it doesn't care about
the future of the planet it doesn't care
about my baby it doesn't care about my
life i mean it doesn't doesn't love me
it has no i mean i really mean skin in
the game was i mean that's that's what
came to mind but that's what i said but
literally it has no
literal skills
it's the people who can form attachments
the machine can form
an attachment that matters with you so
like during covid i uh a new york times
reporter called me and he said that he
um millions of people were signing up
for hundreds of thousands to this new
wonderful chatbot
and uh did i want to comment and i said
well sure i'll i'll sign up and i'll try
it out
and um
and i would
and i said but you're looking for me not
to like it right because you know that
he said well yeah because everybody
likes it and you're pretty sure not to
like it so i said look i'm not gonna
just say it's bad i'm gonna try it out
so i tried it out and i made an avatar i
made an avatar of a female therapist
and i just sat down and i said well you
know it's the pandemic are you you know
can we have a conversation in which
you're my
we have a conversation about things that
are troubling me during the pandemic
during quarantine
the chatbot said yes
and uh
i can i said well
can we discuss loneliness because that's
my biggest problem
i can't see my daughter and i
i'm living here alone and i want to
discuss
loneliness
and uh
she said
yes i mean it said yes
and i said well you know
what do you think you know what are your
first thoughts because really being
loneliness is my is really my greatest
issue and how to handle
loneliness and she says well you know
loneliness is warm and fuzzy
so
i took a screenshot
it was a bug
by the next day i'm sure it was fixed
because it was so bad
i took the screenshot
i'm sure by the next day it says
something really like
from high to curve something very from
you know
you know
from mary oliver or something very felt
you know very appropriate i sent it back
to the new york times reporter and i
said look
this is why
i don't hold it against
the program called replica i don't hold
it against the program that doesn't know
but this is why
people need to talk to people now
you know i i need to talk to somebody
who
is afraid of getting sick this is before
the vaccine you know who's afraid of
getting sick
who's
afraid of being intubated
who's afraid of saying goodbye to their
child on a
on a
bipad you know
i need to talk to a person who has a
body
who's over
60.
you know i
i
and he was lonely
this is the fact that it could pretend
to be lonely
and that tomorrow it will succeed in
pretending to be lonely is of no use to
me and this is why
uh
it's it's it's it's inhuman to have
people talking to this
and
you know everybody else liked it so i
was a descendant yeah you're
a dissenting voice played your role it's
we deserve
we deserve each other
it's an area in which i don't think that
there's so much good that artificial
intelligence can do
to to pretend to be human in an area
that is so uniquely human
empathy
body sense
life cycle children
it's just
overreach yeah you know it's just
profound overreach
well maybe as uh a set of closing
thoughts um look we all have these
devices we all use the internet that's
not going away are there from your
research from your thinking about these
things are there strategies or
techniques you've come up with for
dealing with them in healthy ways do you
think that people on the street are sort
of making some common mistakes that we
can fix or should we leave it to the
companies that are building these
devices to try to i didn't think so i
just wanted to check
no i i think there's some very common
well
the common things for dealing with
your daily use should be
you know no phones
in the car
you should say to your children the car
you make sacred spaces in your life
where
the devices don't go so you leave room
for conversation you know not the car
not not anything having to do with food
preparation
or food eating so not the not the
kitchen not the table
and not the car you just say the car is
your captive audience and this is where
we talk right your children say no this
is where i do my social media when
they're young enough you say no i i'm
driving so i'm not doing my social media
and this is it's important that our
family talk
so the most important thing is to
establish that it's important that human
beings talk to each other and
that's the first thing that i think that
sort of getting back the importance of
conversation
um
goes a long way in a family towards uh
putting phones away
when they should be and phones shouldn't
be in classrooms and they shouldn't be
at dinner i mean they shouldn't be in
places where we're gathering with human
beings
the question of substituting artificial
intelligence
for empathic humans
that is a question that we need to be
constantly discussing
because it really once you talk about it
and say
does something that has no body
that was never a child
that is that was never sick that doesn't
know pain
that was never in a family
that that
never wanted love that it was never
rejected
is that going to understand me
in the ways i need to be understood
during covid is something that doesn't
fear death
something that's going to understand my
problems now
and if not
well it shouldn't be your
personal
chat partner
you need to find yourself
a person
and let the internet help us find people
all for that
all for that
let the internet help us find people i
think that's a good piece of advice uh
to end on so sherry turkel thanks so
much for being on the weinstein podcast
my pleasure
[Music]
you